the doctoral program is extremely
selective so we're taking less than ten
percent of the applicants that apply
each year and we get a fantastic group
of applicants from all over the world
and from a huge range of disciplines
that share an interest in the
environment but really range from the
social sciences through natural and
physical sciences alder element is
working at a really fascinating
intersection between biological
diversity of crops and food security and
it's arena that we really don't know
very much about but we do know that
diversity of crops is disappearing
really fast all around the world in
these developing countries and at what
consequence to people's health and their
well-being I'm interested in local and
traditional crops and crop varieties so
things like the blue maze that comes
from Mexico or those funny shaped
Highland potatoes from the Andes and
there's been a lot of concern over the
last sort of 30 to 50 years that some of
these older varieties that we call
heirloom varieties in the States will be
entirely lost because of because of
agricultural modernization the big
research question is how do some of
these sort of traditional agricultural
methods or these traditional foods how
do they play into household nutrition
and food culture and sort of what part
did they play in what women feed their
families so there's a tendency for
people to look at issues around food and
hunger as if they were mostly economic
issues but there are a lot of other
factors that contribute to them their
their culture cultural and social and
political factors and those are the
things I'm interested in in my research
what our doctoral students bring to the
table I think is that they chose to go
to an interdisciplinary program as
opposed to a disciplinary program all of
them are exceedingly talented they could
have gotten into these programs but
they've chose a harder path they chose
to interact with people who are doing
work much different than them across the
that any cohort in our class you have
economists you have people working on
Biological Diversity sitting next to
sociologists and they feed off of each
other that makes them broader in their
conception of these problems and I think
more effective I'm in the field of
biology
chemistry but how that relates to me is
I basically look at the chemistry of
carbon how it moves through plants
through soils and into water systems and
all the interacting mechanisms in all of
those systems and how it changes carbon
and moves it to the oceans so David's
research is on the economy of carbon and
rivers and in essence what he's showing
is that they're the Constitution and the
amount of carbon that is coming out of
these rivers is globally significant and
it's going to change the way we model
the global circulation of carbon and the
way that we forecast climate change so
what I do is I spend most of my time on
a boat cruising this 12-mile stretch and
I have this really sophisticated sensor
equipment that pumps water through and
it basically takes very intense
photographs the water where we can look
at the molecular structure of the carbon
instantaneously and then we can also
measure the concentration of co2 and
it's very concentrated so you can sort
of think of it as a river breathing you
have all the co2 in the water moving out
into the atmosphere and one of the
really bit exciting parts of my research
has shown that these rivers breathe a
lot of car you know they are a source of
co2 just like we breathe co2 just like
smoke stacks or you know pumping out co2
these rivers emit co2 and it's never
really been factored into global models
yet Mercedes Bravo is doing tremendously
important work on air pollution
essentially she's taking forecasting of
air pollution and the potential health
consequences outside of the bounds of
where people have looked before
especially into these rural populations
where you have people who are
tremendously vulnerable and where we
don't have a lot of information so we
know there's air pollution in urban
areas and this is where we have our
monitoring network so this is where we
have our data so we are able to figure
out what's happening in urban areas
within reason but in rural areas there's
this sort of thought that there that
pollution isn't a problem that pollution
levels aren't high but there's still
people that live in rural areas there
are still economic activities that
happen in rural
is agriculture and so on things that can
be affected by air pollution and so my
job is sort of to figure out what's
happening in the roller areas what kind
of pollutants are out there at what
level one of the most exciting parts of
what I do sort of particular to this
project this isn't sort of big picture
but rather little picture is that with
the area that the model covers were
actually able to estimate health effects
for an extra 50 million people than we
would be just using the monitoring data
we have students studying really an
enormous range of things we have
students who are spending a lot of their
time in China understanding how this
emerging economy is dealing with
environmental challenges as it's growing
at such enormous rates we have students
who are or doing work that's going to
help us much better understand the
causes of and forecast the consequences
of climate change we have students that
are trying to understand how we can
forestall extinction of species really a
huge range of folks many of them perhaps
even most end up working remotely from
campus and many of those are working
internationally the doctoral program at
the school for sri environmental studies
was just reviewed by the National
Research Council and we received a top
rating so we're pretty excited about
that but as our the president of our
university has said these rankings don't
mean very much but boy it feels pretty
nice
you